The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: So welcome
back, everybody, to 8.03.
Happy to see you again.
So here is the current
status of the 8.03.
So right now, we have
finished the discussion
of coupled oscillator.
And then we go to infinite
number of coupled oscillators.
And we found that there's a
wave equation coming out of it.
And that means, in short, waves
are really a group effort.
So many, many objects are
working really together,
so that they create
a wave phenomena.
And you can also see,
there's a close connection
between vibration
of a single object
and the formation of
the wave structure.
So what we are
going to do today is
to give you a short review of
what we have done last time.
Then we actually will
continue to our understanding
of wave equation today.
So what we have
learned last time,
we have learned how to solve
infinite system with space
translation symmetry.
And also, we learned
how to use it
to solve finite systems
by imposing-- or adding
boundary conditions.
That would limit the infinite
number of normal modes
to finite number of
normal modes based on--
I mean, it's actually
closely related
to how many objects
you have in the system.
And also, we went ahead and
go to a continuum limit.
And we found out, there is a
surprising result coming out
of this.
And this is actually
the wave equation.
So what do we mean by
going to continuous limit?
So the limit we
are talking about
is that, before when we
discussed this closed
system of infinite number
of objects holding together
by strings, there is
a length scale, which
is the separation
between objects, which
is called a in my notation.
And to make it continuous,
we are taking a limit such
that the a, which is the
separation between objects,
is so much smaller
than the wavelength.
Basically, the
wavelength is actually
the sinusoidal shape you
see when I perturb a system.
And what I assuming is that
the distance between objects
are so much smaller
than the wavelengths.
So that's actually what I
called continuous limit.
And that is actually true for
most of the example, which we
see in the previous lectures.
For example, I was
holding a giant spring.
And I oscillate that.
And all the little
components, or, say,
all the little mass on that
spring, the space between all
those little mass on the
spring are so much smaller
than the length scale
we are talking about,
which is at the
order of 1 meter.
So that actually is
a sensible limit,
which describes the
physics we are interested.
When we go to a
continuous limit,
we find that something
really interesting happens.
So M minus 1 K matrix
originally is infinite times
infinite dimension matrix.
It becomes the operator,
which is actually
minus T over rho L partial
square partial x squared.
And also--
OK, I changed the notation here.
It was aj, and I
changed it to psi,
because what we are going to
use later on, when we describe
wave functions, et cetera,
especially in 8.04,
we usually use psi.
And the psi j, which were
discrete and evaluated
in the individual discrete
position in the x direction,
it's becoming a
continuous function,
which is psi x and
is also a function t.
Therefore, from
this exercise, we
found out we see wave
equation, actually after we
go to a continuous limit.
And for more
information, you can also
take a look at the textbook
in the relevant page.
So what are we
going to do today?
So today, what we
are going to do
is to understand the wave
equation, the structure,
and what does that
mean, and also
what are the normal modes coming
out of this wave equation.
And the next time,
in later lectures,
we will also discuss another
special kind of motion, which
is progressing wave solutions.
So let's immediately
gets started
by looking at a concrete
example and also
to derive the normal modes
from this wave equation.
Before we do that, let's take
a look at this wave equation.
This wave equation is actually
equivalent to infinite
number of equations of
motion, if you think about it.
Why is that?
That is because each x--
each partition x you put in will
produce a equation of motion.
So basically, originally, when
we were doing a discrete case,
those are labeled by c.
c is actually telling you
which mass I'm talking about.
Now, it's actually
replaced by x.
And what we are
actually doing is
to solve infinite number
equation of motion in one go.
And that is actually
the wave equation.
So the first question we ask is,
what is actually normal modes
based on this infinitely long
continuous system described
by wave equations?
So let's get
started immediately.
So basically, we
can first assume
what is actually the functional
form for normal modes.
So what we can
actually do is we can
assume that psi x, t
is actually equal to A,
is actually a function
of x, times B,
is actually a function of time.
So what I am doing is actually
have a meaning actually.
So A of x actually
give you a description
of the functional form--
the shape of the normal
mode as a function of x.
So that's actually
giving you the shape
as a function of x-axis.
And B, which is a
function of t, is actually
giving you information
how individual component
goes up and down or move
as a function of time.
So that actually control
the time evolution.
And we were using
this wave equation
to describe a continuous
system, like, for example,
a string with tension t.
So what we could do
is the following.
So we are interested in
the solution of the wave
equation, which is shown there.
So what we could do is
that, OK, let's first assume
this functional form, assuming
that every component is
actually following the
same time-depend evolution.
And then we can actually
plug in this functional form
to the equation of motion
and see what we will get.
So if we plug this in
into the wave equation,
so what we are going to get is,
if you look at the left hand
side, it's actually a partial
derivation with respect
to time.
Therefore, what we
are going to get
is A of x times partial square
of B, which is a function of t,
partial t squared.
The right hand side
of the equation,
which is actually
equal to vp squared,
is a partial derivative
with respect to x.
Therefore, you have
B is a function of t
only times partial square
A of x partial t squared.
So actually, we can
just for convenience--
oh, sorry, that's
supposed to be partial x.
Thank you very much--
partial x squared.
So just for convenience,
we can actually
divide the whole equation by A
times B times the vp squared.
We can issue divide the
whole equation by A times B,
for example, and the vp squared.
If we do this,
then basically I'm
moving this part to
the left hand side.
So I get 1 over vp square B of
t partial square Bt partial t
square.
And the right hand side, because
I also divide AB vp square,
therefore, I get 1 over A of x
partial square A of x partial
x square.
So far so good.
And basically, what
I'm doing is just
plug in the functional
form, which I assume here
and then divide everything
by AB times vp square.
And what I immediately
find is that left hand
side is a function
which only depends on t.
Left hand side
only depends on t.
And right hand
side is a function
which on the depends on x.
So in short, I have
in this situation
f of t, which is left hand
side, is equal to g of x.
You will see this over and over
again in later lectures related
to physics.
This is actually the so-called
separation of variables.
So basically, you are
facing a situation
f of t equal to g of x.
If you think about
this situation,
that's actually
really, really helpful,
because, OK, now what I can do
is I can stay at a specific x.
For example, I
choose this point.
Then I let the time go forward.
Of course, I cannot stop
time, but if it goes forward,
then left hand side
equivalent, if it's changing,
you will change,
because I change t.
If the left hand side
equation is changing,
then that's actually
not going to--
this equation is
not going to work,
because I am not changing x.
I am fixing myself at a specific
location, and a lot of time
go on.
Then if left hand
side is changing,
then this equation cannot work.
You see?
Therefore, what is the
consequence of this equation?
That means, left hand side,
f of t, must be a constant.
Therefore, no matter what
I do, if I change time,
it's not going to
change anything.
I can put in whatever
time, like 1 billion years
after this lecture or
now, it doesn't matter.
It's a constant.
So this must be a constant.
I can do the same trick.
I froze the time.
I fix the time, and then
I compare this point
to that point, or, say,
something billion billions
of light years away
from this class room.
I am changing the x, but
I'm not changing the t.
The same argument also holds--
if this function is
changing as a function of x,
then I am screwed, because--
[LAUGHTER]
--it doesn't work, right?
I mean, this--
Therefore, it has to be
a constant also as well.
Constant also equal
to a constant,
that's really lovely, right?
[LAUGHS] That means,
I can say this
is equal to that is
equal to a constant.
As usual, I call this constant
really, really strange
fancy name-- minus Km square,
which you will not like it.
But later, you would like it.
[LAUGHTER]
Very good.
So we make tremendous
amount of progress.
Originally, we saw
that we are in trouble.
It's A times Bt--
Ax times Bt, sounds
really horrible.
Now, actually, you
see that this equation
is really simple to solve.
So let's actually take
a look at the solution
to the f function
and the g function.
So the first thing, if I
take the left hand side,
which is a time-dependence
part, I can copy there--
this is actually 1--
copy the equivalent here--
is 1 over vp square B of t
partial square Bt partial t
square.
And this is equal
to a fancy name
of this constant--
minus Km square.
And of course, I can multiply
everything by vp squared B.
And I get partial square
B partial t square.
And this is equal too
minus vp square Km square
B. Wait a second.
We have solved this
equation infinite number
of times in this lecture.
You remember the solution?
What is the solution?
Anybody can help me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YEN-JIE LEE: Anybody?
It's sine or cosine
function, right?
This is harmonic oscillation.
It's almost like equation of
motion of a spring-mass system,
right?
I hope that you
are already bored.
And that means I
very successful.
[LAUGHTER]
B of t will be equal to--
[LAUGHS]---- B of m sine
omega m t plus beta m,
where omega m is actually
equal to vp times Km.
I define omega m
equal to vp time Km.
So surprisingly, the solution
of B is really simple.
It's actually Bm sine
omega m t plus beta m.
So what does that mean?
That means the overall motion
or overall time-dependent
evolution of the system
is like harmonic motion.
If you do get individual
component in this system.
So that's really nice.
So let's take a look
at the right hand side.
The right hand side
what we have is
1 over A A of x partial
square A x partial x squared.
And now, this equal
to minus Km squared.
I don't want to go
over this again.
This is actually the
same thing as number one.
The only thing
which is different
is that now the partial
derivative is actually the x.
It's partial square
A partial x square.
Therefore, I can immediately
write down the solution.
A of t-- oh, sorry--
A of x will be equal to
Cm sine Km x plus alpha m.
Any questions so far?
So until now, you accept the
fact that f of t and the g of x
has to be the same constant.
And I call it minus Km square.
And I didn't actually tell
you what Km I'm choosing.
In reality, according to this
result, Km can the anything,
can be any number, as
long as it's a constant.
Therefore, I would like to write
the corresponding psi, which
is the wave function, is
actually labeled by m.
m is it just label which K
I was using, nothing fancy.
It's just a label.
Psi of m is a
function of x and t.
And that will be equal to
Bm times Cm sine omega mt
plus beta m sine
Km x plus alpha m.
Bm and Cm are just
arbitrary constant.
Therefore, I can merge them.
And I will call it just Am.
And, of course, don't forget
we have this condition.
Omega m is actually
equal to vp times Km.
So this is actually
defined here.
So here, since this is actually
a second order differential
equation, you have unknown
factor, which is beta m.
You have also Bm is a unknown.
And the right hand
side, you also
have a Cm, which is unknown,
and alpha m, which is unknown.
When we combine them, I
replace Bm times Cm by Am.
Therefore, what we have
is that Am is actually
some kind of amplitude,
which can be determined
by initial conditions, which
I will talk about that later.
Beta m is the unknown coming
from the left hand side
derivation.
Alpha m is also unknown,
which is actually
coming from the right
side derivation related
to the shape of the
normal mode of the system.
And finally, there's one
additional unknown coefficient,
which is Km--
it's kind of arbitrary now--
control actually
the wave number,
or say the wavelength of the
shape of the normal mode.
So when you see this,
doesn't this surprise you?
May not surprise you
any more, because we
have solved infinite number
of coupled oscillator.
And you have learned
that, OK, the normal modes
have a shape of sine function.
It's like a sine function--
before it was like
a sine as a Ka.
And the Ka is performing x.
So what we are
actually getting here
is that doesn't surprise you
since this system also satisfy
space translational symmetry.
Therefore, the functional form
of the shape of the normal mode
is also a sine function.
So that's actually
pretty satisfactory
and also come out as what we
would expect based on what
we actually have learned.
So let's actually take a look at
the structure of this function.
So basically, as I
mentioned before,
everything is oscillating
at the frequency omega m
with a phase beta m.
So that satisfy the
condition of normal mode,
what is the condition.
All the components
in the system are
oscillating at the same
frequency and the same phase.
Indeed, yes, that's correct.
Also as a function of
time, it's actually
going up and down harmonically
as we already discussed.
And the relative amplitude,
as I said, is a sine function.
And of course, I already
demonstrated this before,
that you can see that
in this is system,
you can see a sine function
when I start to drive it.
So what I am doing is actually
to convert the kinetic energy
from my hand to energy stored
as potential or kinetic energy
in this string-rod system and
in this bell wave machine.
So you can see that beautifully
those are sine function.
And, of course, if I do
a higher frequency one,
you can see the hand
oscillation frequency changed.
And that is actually
controlled by this equation,
this dispersion relation.
And this dispersion
relation is actually
relating two physical quantity.
One is actually the wave number.
Of course, if you are more
familiar with wavelength,
it's actually 2 pi over Km.
Lambda m is actually
the wavelength
of the shape of the normal mode.
And the oscillation
frequency is actually
controlled by this dispersion
relation, this function.
And you can say
that, Professor Lee,
I have been so
tired of this demo.
I've seen this
1,000 times, right?
And basically,
you are showing me
that, OK, you can actually
oscillate this system
and excite this
system so that it's
oscillating at some natural
frequency the system
like, right?
It's actually some kind
of resonance behavior.
So I can actually excite--
I can-- no.
I can randomly
shake this system.
And then it's going to be
a linear combination of all
the excited normal modes, right?
We have seen this
many, many times.
What I am going to show you is
that there's another machine
here, which is
actually demonstrating
the resonance of some wave.
So here is actually
so-called the Rijke tube.
So the structure is like this.
So basically, you have a metal
tube, which is red thing there.
And inside the tube--
you cannot see it now--
but inside the tube,
there's a wire mesh, which the
air can flow freely up and down
in this mesh.
And what I'm going to do
now is to heat up the mesh
and see what is going to happen.
I will just heat it
up by like six second
and see what is going to happen.
So now, I'm going to
do this very carefully.
[RESONATING SOUND]
Can you hear that?
[LAUGHS] OK, very good.
So listen, what is happening?
So you hear a mono frequency
sound generated from what?
Generated from the heat
I gave to the wire mesh.
So what is actually happening?
So when I heat up the mesh,
what is going to happen
is that the air
around this screen
is going to be heated up.
Therefore, because
the air is heated up,
it goes in the upward direction.
And also, the
volume of the air is
expanding, because of the
increased temperature.
And that actually goes
through this system.
And why it does is really like
what I'm doing to the bell lab
wave machine, is actually
tyring to oscillate-- or excite
any possible normal modes,
which this system actually like.
So you can see that, after
a while, once the pressure
and also the air inside the
tube get then self-organized,
then you hear a very loud sound.
So that means there are
energy flowing from the tube
to your ear.
And that is actually
coming from what?
Coming from the heat
I put into the system.
So it's actually a heat
sound wave conversion.
So I hope you enjoyed this demo.
And we will take a
five-minute break
to take questions
before we move on.
And of course, you are
welcome to come here
and to play with the
demo if you want.
[LAUGHS]
So welcome back from the break.
So what we are
going to do next is
to understand how to determine
all those unknown coefficients.
So you get to see here, there
are Am, which is the amplitude.
There are beta m, which
is basically the phase.
There are Km, which is
actually the wave number,
and alpha m, which is
the phase for the shape.
So what I'm going to show you
is that Am and the beta m,
these two quantity
will be determined
by initial conditions.
Well, Km and alpha
m, as you may guess,
those can be determined
by boundary condition
for the Km and alpha m.
So why don't we
just immediately get
started with a concrete example.
So let's take a look
at this situation.
So this equation and
those all the possible Km
are allowed when we talk
about infinitely long system.
So far, we have not imposed
any boundary conditions.
And what I'm going to do now is
to show you a example boundary
condition and see how we can
actually fix Km and alpha m.
So suppose we are
interested in this system.
So I have a wall in
the left hand side.
And I have a string
with length L.
And it's actually
connected to massless ring.
And this ring can actually
move up and down a long rod
in the right hand side.
And I also assume that this
string have a constant tension
T. And also the
density is rho L.
So basically, it's a
mass per unit length.
So that's the system
which I am interested.
And, of course, I need to define
my coordinate system as usual.
I define horizontal
direction to be x direction.
And I define the vertical
direction to be y direction.
And I define y equal
to 0 is the equilibrium
portion of the string.
When psi is equal to 0, that
means this string is actually
at rest.
And not moving-- is actually
in the equilibrium position,
it's not displaced at all
with respect to y equal to 0.
And I can also define
that x equal to 0
is the position of the
left hand side wall.
So this is actually
the physical situation.
And I would like to
actually find out what
are the boundary conditions.
So what are the
boundary condition?
So from what we actually
discussed last time,
left hand side, since this
string is actually fixed
on the wall, I nailed it
there, it cannot move.
Therefore, what is actually
the first boundary condition?
Why is actually the
first boundary condition?
Anybody can tell me?
Which describes the situation,
the physical situation
on your left hand side?
AUDIENCE: y0 is 0.
YEN-JIE LEE: y0 is 0.
Very good.
So when x is equal
to 0, y0 is 0.
So on my note, I was using
a different notation.
So I would just use psi.
So psi 0 is equal to 0.
Apparently, there's another
boundary of this system.
The other boundary
condition is actually
happening at x equal to L.
What is actually the boundary
condition?
Can somebody help me?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it the
derivative of psi is 0?
YEN-JIE LEE: The derivative
of the psi is equal to 0.
So we will explain to
everybody why is that the case.
The answer proposed is that
partial psi partial x L
t is equal to 0.
And this is 0, t,
because that has
to be true no matter when I
actually invented this boundary
condition.
So what is actually giving
us this strange boundary
condition?
So suppose I focus on the
force diagram on this ring.
So this ring is
actually connected
to a string with
string tension T. Also,
there's another force
which is actually
trying to balance the
string tension, which
is a normal force--
normal force coming from
the rod, which is actually
trying to stop the
ring from moving
in the horizontal direction.
So there's normal force then.
And we also know that this
ring is actually massless.
So m is equal to 0.
Suppose that this partial psi
partial x, the slope is not 0.
If slope is not 0, that means
the string may be pulling
this ring to some direction.
What is going to happen?
So if this happens, it is
actually clear that the normal
force cannot balance
the string for us.
Everybody get it?
What will happen?
If this happened, then
this massless ring
will suffer from infinitely
large acceleration.
Because F is equal to ma.
And m is 0, so a
goes to infinity.
So that means this ring
will- peeew- disappear, go
to the edge of the universe.
Did that happen?
No, it didn't happen.
Therefore, this condition
must be satisfied.
You see?
So the slope of the
string cannot be nonzero.
Otherwise, some
crisis will happen.
Very good.
So we have the two conditions.
And the second thing, which we
are going to demonstrate you,
is that, OK, I promise you
that boundary condition can
fix these two constants.
So therefore, we are
going to demonstrate that.
So let's use the first condition
we have in the right hand side
board.
And basically, from 1, you
can actually get psi m 0, t.
I am plugging in
this condition--
plugging in this solution to
boundary condition number 1.
And basically, what
I am going to get
is this is equal to Am
sine alpha m sine omega m t
plus beta m.
And this is actually equal to 0.
So you only have a
alpha m here because I
am setting x to be equal to 0.
I'm setting x to be equal to 0.
Therefore, you already
have that functional form.
So now, we are facing a choice.
So you can set Am to be equal
to 0 is arbitrary number.
But if you set m equal
to 0, everything is 0.
And it's not fun,
it's not moving.
Therefore, I don't want to
set Am to be equal to 0.
And you can say, huh,
maybe this is equal to 0--
sine omega m t plus
beta m is equal to 0.
But this is really
a sine function.
And this condition has
to be satisfied no matter
at which time you are revisiting
this boundary condition.
At all times, this boundary
condition has to be satisfied.
Therefore, this
cannot be equal to 0.
Therefore, I conclude
that this is the 0.
So what does that mean?
That means I can choose
alpha m is equal to 0.
So that's actually given by
the first boundary condition.
So let's actually take a look at
the second boundary condition--
partial psi partial x evaluated
at x equal to L and any time t
is equal to 0.
So now, I can plug in,
again, the solution
in the middle board partial
psi m L, t, partial x.
And that will be equal to Am
Km sine omega m t plus beta m
cosine Km x.
And this is equal to 0.
So I am taking a partial
derivative partial psi
partial x.
Therefore, the
sine become cosine.
The sine Km x plus
alpha m becoming cosine.
And also, I know already from
the first boundary condition,
alpha m is equal to 0.
Therefore, I get
cosine Km x here.
And this is evaluated
at x equal to L.
So that means this
thing must be equal to 0
based on the second
boundary condition.
Of course, we can have
a losing argument--
Am should not be equal to 0.
Otherwise, you will be
equal to 0 all the time,
the whole wave function is 0.
And this is actually
changing as a function
of time, the same argument,
because this boundary condition
has to be satisfied
at all times.
From the beginning
of the Universe
to the end of the Universe, this
condition has to be satisfied.
Therefore, these
cannot be equal to 0.
And what is actually left over
is cosine Km x evaluated at L
equal to 0.
So cosine Km L is equal to 0.
So that means you cannot
arbitrarily choose Km anymore.
Before we introduced boundary
conditions, we were saying, ah,
Km is actually some
arbitrary constant.
And now, it's not
arbitrary any more.
It has to satisfy
this condition.
What does that mean?
This means that Km
has to be equal to 2m
minus 1 divided by 2L times pi.
You can actually check this.
And this small m is equal to
1, 2, 3, et cetera, et cetera.
And then you can
see that there are
many, many different solutions.
So you can see that,
as I mentioned before,
the boundary conditions
determine Km and alpha m.
So you can see that the first
condition at x equal to 0
determine alpha m.
The second boundary
condition also
help us to determine what
are the possible Km value.
And that is actually
listed here.
Any questions?
No?
So in order to help
you to visualize
what we have
learned from here, I
can now choose m is equal to 1.
So you can see that I
carefully choose my notation
from the beginning.
So therefore, m is now the
index of the normal mode
I am referring to.
So now, if I choose
m equal to 1,
then I can actually
evaluate what
would be the resulting K. So
K1, according to last formula 2
minus 1 is giving you 1.
Therefore, you'll
get pi over 2L.
And, of course, you
can also calculate
based on the wave number
what will be the wavelength.
So the wavelength lambda 1
will be equal to 2 pi over K1.
Wine And that will give you 4L.
Don't forget, once you
actually already decide K,
the omega is also
determined, because omega,
which is the angular
frequency of this normal mode,
is determined by that
dispersion relation omega
m equal to vp times Km.
So therefore, I can
now calculate omega 1.
That will be equal
to vp times K1.
And that will you square root
of T over rho L pi over 2L.
So this is actually coming
from the last lecture,
the formula of vp.
So that means, if you fix the
shape of you are normal mode,
then the angular
frequency is also fixed,
according to this
dispersion relation.
So of course, I can now
visualize this situation.
And basically, I can plot this
system as a function of time--
as a function of x, not
as a function of time.
So when this system reach
the maxima amplitude,
it would look like this.
And this is actually
amplitude A1.
Because I am talking about the
first normal mode labeled by m
equal to 1, and there is
an unknown amplitude A1.
And that is actually
showing here.
Of course, I can go
ahead and calculate
if m is equal to 2,
what is going to happen?
If I increase the m,
what is going to happen
is that K is also increased.
So K is increased.
Then that means the
wavelength is decreased.
I have calculated the K for you.
And that is equal
to 3 pi over 2L.
And those are the lambda 2
will be equal to 4L over 3.
You can actually double
check this at home.
And of course, I
can now demonstrate
what would be the resulting
shape of the massless mode.
It would look like this.
And this is essentially
telling you the amplitude A2.
You can also do m equal to 3.
If you doing that,
basically what you get
is something like this,
et cetera, et cetera.
Any questions?
And the motion of this system
that is a function of time
is that this whole
shape, this shape,
is multiplied by sine
omega m t plus beta m.
So the whole shape is going to
scale up and down harmonically.
And so if you focus on
one of the point here,
it's going to be going
up and down harmonically.
Very important, there's no
back and forth movement.
Everything is only
moving up and down.
If you focus on only one of
the particle in this string,
everything is
moving up and down.
Like here, right?
So when I create a curve--
when I create some kind of wave,
all the components are always
moving only up and down,
instead of back and forth,
because they can't.
They can't move back and forth.
But you maybe cheated by
the shape-- the evolution
as a boundary of
time, it seems to me
that, ah, something is
actually moving back and forth.
But never-- all the particles
are moving up and down--
very important.
Finally, we have shown you
the first three normal modes.
And what is actually the
most general solution?
What is a general solution?
Of course, as we had
before, general solution
would be a linear combination of
all the possible normal modes.
So now, I would like
to write psi x, t,
as the general solution is
going to be the sum of all
the allowed normal mode.
In this specific
case, it's going
to be a summation from 1--
m equal to 1 to infinity Am sine
omega m t plus beta m sine Km x
plus alpha m.
And in this specific
case, it become cosine--
the Km is there--
cosine 2m minus 1--
sorry, it should be sine.
It should be sine 2m
minus 1 over 2L pi.
And the alpha m in this
case is equal to 0.
So the upper formula is
the most general case.
You're summing over
the possible m's.
And the Km and alpha
m can be determined
by boundary conditions.
And in this specific case,
the right hand side expression
is reading like sine 2m
minus 1 over 2L times pi.
So that's very nice.
And then you can see
another sets of example
here in the slide.
So this is another
set of normal modes
from m equal to 1
to m equal to 6.
And you can see
that in this example
both ends are fixed, instead
of one end is actually
attached to a massless ring.
If both ends are fixed, then
you get these normal modes.
And of course, in the later--
in your p set, you
will be exercising
this kind of normal
modes and solve
the corresponding
Km and alpha m.
And you can see that, if you
focus on the upper left corner,
you will see that the
oscillation frequency is low.
Why is that?
That is because the wave
number Km is small, therefore,
wavelength is long.
According to that
formula, omega m
is proportional to wave number.
Therefore, you can see that
the oscillation frequency
is actually two
times slower compared
to m equal to 2 case, which
is the upper right corner
result And you can see that, if
you increase m more and more,
you get larger and larger
K. And therefore, you
see that the oscillation
frequency is getting larger
and larger.
So now, we are actually
facing an issue here.
Wait a second, so now we
have solved the functional
form of the normal mode.
We have learned how to
determine Km and alpha m.
But we are facing
a difficulty here,
because Am is very
difficult to solve,
because you have infinite
number of terms here.
And beta m, how
do we solve this?
So it's getting really,
really difficult.
So what I am going
to tell you is
that we can actually, again,
use the help from the math
department.
They have actually
proposed the solution.
They actually say that,
huh, this is actually
identical problem that we
solved in the math department,
is just for the decomposition
and for the series.
So what is actually
for the series?
So you can see, from
here, there's a triangular
shape between 0 and 1.
It's a function-- probably
is a function of x.
And between 0 and 1, it
looks like a triangle.
And if you do for
the decomposition,
it can be decomposed
as small k sine
function plus the
second normal mode
and plus a second massless mode.
And you can see that, if you
increase the number of terms
included in this
Fourier series, then
you will see that
the shape is actually
getting closer and closer
to the triangular shape.
In order to help you
with the visualization,
here is actually
what I prepared.
So this actually extracted from
essentially a real example,
which I really used a
computer to calculate.
And I tracked the contribution
from m equal to 1.
This means that the first
term in this summation--
infinite number of
term summation--
the first term looks like this.
And if you include the first
and second and third term,
it becomes something
like a plateau.
And then if you
increase 1 to 5, it's
evolving as a function of m,
becoming more and more-- hm,
strange shape.
And that is actually including
the summation from first term
to 11 terms and,
finally, 11 to 19.
Huh, what this is--
what is actually the
function I put in?
It's actually a MIT function!
[LAUGHTER]
I put in a MIT function
into this again.
And you can see that--
wow, 1 to 59 term.
I need to use 59
terms to describe
this really wonderful shape.
[LAUGHS] So in order to help
you with the visualization,
listen you can see I prepared a
little program, which actually
can show you the evolutions as I
increase more and more m terms.
Let's take a look.
You can see that,
originally it looks--
doesn't look-- oh, you
cannot see anything.
Wait a second.
What is going on?
Let me see if I can--
I hope I don't screw this up.
Sorry.
I need to restart.
So let's get started.
So you can see that from
the first few terms,
it doesn't look anything.
But very soon, when you have
20 terms added to each other,
it looks really pretty
much like a MIT dome.
And you can see that
this program is really
trying really hard to
describe the sharp edge
in the left-hand side
and the right-hand side.
You can see that those kind of
really infinitely sharp edge
will need infinite
number of terms,
so that if your
m is really huge,
then the K, the wave number,
is going to infinity.
Then you can actually
produce infinitely sharp edge
in this function.
And that is actually, you can
see from this demonstration
the program is really
struggling with this really
super sharp edge.
So look at the left hand side
and right hand side corner,
originally the slope is
clearly not high enough.
And thus, we include higher,
higher m value terms.
And you can see the description
becoming much, much better
at the edge but,
of course, still
are not perfect, because you
need infinite number of terms
to describe the
shape of MIT dome.
Of course, we can also take
a look at other example,
just testing my eyesight
I'm not sure if I--
OK, so I can increase the
speed to save on time.
So this is actually
a square pulse,
which you can see from the
scope pretty often when
you do experiment.
And you can see that a square
pulse is really difficult
to reproduce, as I said before,
due to these sharply rising h.
And of course, I can
also demonstrate you
another example, which
is a triangular shape.
And you can see that--
ah, still, you can see
it works pretty nicely.
And the function doesn't like
at all the right hand side
edge, because of
exactly the same reason.
OK, very good.
So let's come back
to the presentation.
Can you see-- OK, very good.
So the question is, how do we
actually extract Am and beta m?
OK, I have done that
with a computer program.
And what I'm going to do now is
to show you a concrete example.
And we are going to
go through it together
to see how we actually
can extract Am and beta m.
So suppose I give you
an initial condition.
It's exactly the same
system I am talking about.
But now, I prepare
this system at t
equal to 0 some
specific kind of shape.
This L/2 is actually the
first half of the system,
is actually untouched.
The first part of the
string is actually
at the equilibrium position.
And this is actually
x equal to L/2.
Suddenly, I actually move
the string sharply up.
And the rest half of
the string is actually
at the height of h in this case.
And of course, the right hand
side edge is x equal to L.
And this is actually a
snapshot, which I actually took
with my camera at t equal to 0.
And also, I assume that at
t equal to 0, the string--
all the components of
the string is at rest.
So based on this information,
which I give you,
I can now translate this
information into mathematics.
So that corresponds to
two initial conditions.
The first one is
that, since the string
is at rest, that means psi dot x
evaluated at t equal to 0 is 0,
because the string is at rest.
The second initial condition
is that psi x 0 is known and is
actually shown in this graph.
So from this, we
would like to see
if we can actually extract
information about capital
Am and the beta m.
So let's immediately get
started to see how we can
use those initial conditions.
So from the first
initial condition, a,
related to the initial velocity
of the string, basically,
we can get psi dot x, t.
And this will be equal to, let's
see, the sum over m equal to 1
to infinity.
So basically, I'm
taking this equation
when I plug in
that equation into
the first initial condition.
So basically, what I have
is Am omega m sine omega m
t plus beta m.
Oh, this will become cosine--
sorry-- because I'm doing
a derivative, psi dot.
So this will become cosine.
And sine Km x plus alpha m.
And this is actually
equal to 0 when
psi dot x, t, is actually
evaluated at t equal to 0.
And this is equal to 0.
So if I plug in t equal to 0 to
this equation, this becomes 0.
And then we know that the
shape of the normal mode
is some kind of sine function
from the previous discussion.
And I am now requiring this
thing to be equal to 0.
Of course, I cannot make
Am omega m equal to 0.
That's what we discussed before.
And this sine function
can be evaluated
at any place, any x value.
Therefore, this
cannot be equal to 0.
Therefore, what is
actually the result?
The resulting condition
is that cosine beta m
will be equal to 0.
Therefore-- huh, from
this initial condition,
actually I can conclude
that beta m is actually
equal to pi/2, for example.
So therefore, you can
see that very clearly
from the first initial
condition, the string
is not moving at
the beginning, I
can conclude that beta
m is equal to pi over 2.
And just as reminder, alpha
m is actually equal to 0
from the previous discussion.
And Km is actually equal to
2m minus 1 pi divided by 2L,
because I just
want to copy here,
because somehow the board
is covered by another board.
So now, I have done with
the first initial condition.
And the other initial
condition I have
is that, OK, I provided
you the picture
I took at the beginning
of the experiment.
Therefore, psi x, 0--
at t equal to 0--
is known.
So very good.
So I have this condition.
But now, I am
facing a difficulty,
because all those terms--
all the terms, m equal
to 1 to infinity--
contribute, as we demonstrated
before, to this shape.
It's very difficult to
actually evaluate Am.
So the trick is to make friends
from the math department.
So what we could
do is that we can
use the orthogonality
of the sine function
to overcome this difficulty.
So let me immediately
write down what do I
mean by orthogonality
of the sine function.
So if I do a integration from 0
to L on dx sine Km x sine Kn x,
if I do this integral,
integrating from 0 to L,
so what I am going to get
is that basically you either
get L equal to 2
if m is equal to n,
or you get 0, if m
is not equal to n.
So basically, I have
two sine functions
multiplied to each other.
And I do integration from 0
to L multiplied by delta x.
And this is Km.
This is Kn.
If Km and Kn are
different, you can actually
go ahead and do this exercise.
And you will find that,
indeed, if they are the same,
then you will get L/2.
On the other hand, if
they are not the same--
the K value are not the same
for the first and second sine
function--
you are going to get 0.
So that's very good news,
because if I do this--
if I do this calculation,
I do 2/L integration from 0
to L psi x, 0,
sine Km x dx, what
is going to happen if
I do this integration?
Remember, psi m is
a linear combination
of infinite number of massless
modes with different sine Km x.
If I multiplied
that by sine Km x,
this is a very
crazy thing to do,
because all the other
terms will become 0.
If the K value of
one of the terms
is not equal to the
dictator's value Km, it's 0.
Otherwise, it's L/2,
and it is designed here
to cancel that factor.
So you can see that this
is like a mode picker.
I'm picking up a
mode with this tool.
This is like, this
tool, yeah, I'm
picking this mode, which
is actually matching my Km.
It's a miracle that
this become Am.
I hope you get this idea,
even if probably you
haven't heard about with
your decomposition before.
But essentially,
what we are doing
is that I'm going to evaluate
infinite number of integrals.
And you are going to do that
in the exam, hopefully easy.
[LAUGHS]
What is going to happen is
that, if you do this integral,
you are going to pick
only one mode out of it.
And you are going
to be able to know
the amplitude of that mode.
So let's do this
immediately in this example.
So Am is actually equal to
2/L. Since the amplitude
is actually 0 between 0 and L/2.
So I can safely just
integrate from L/2 to L.
So I do a integration
from L/2 to L,
because between 0 and L/2,
the initial position is 0.
So what I'm going to
get is h sine Km x dx.
And of course, everybody
know how to do this integral.
It doesn't look that horrible.
And this would become
2/L minus h over Km.
And basically, this will
become cosine Km evaluated
at L minus cosine
Km evaluated at L/2,
and where this Km,
as just a reminder,
is basically equal to 2m
minus 1 pi divided by 2/L.
So I hope this actually help
you to understand the procedure
to determining all those
unknown coefficients,
starting from this equation.
Am and the beta m
can be determined
by initial conditions.
As we actually
show here, you can
use the initial
condition of velocity
and the initial
condition of the shape
and the help of a
mode picker to pick up
the amplitude from
that tool function.
And also, you can see that
Km and alpha m related
to the shape of the normal
mode can be determined
by boundary conditions--
boundary conditions, how this
system is actually connected
to the nearby systems.
The nearby systems are
the rod and the wall.
So that is actually the
two boundary conditions,
which determine the
shape of the normal mode.
And finally, very
important, as usual,
the most general
solution is, of course,
a linear combination of all of
those possible massless modes
from m equal to 1 to infinity.
And omega m, don't forget, is
determined by the dispersion
relation, vp times Kl.
Before the end, I would like
to mention to you something
which you might
actually not notice
when we were discussing this.
So you can see that omega
is now proportional to Km.
So if you plot omega
as a function of k,
actually you can see that
it's becoming a straight line
in this graph, which is
very straightforward.
And on the other
hand, if you remember
what we got last time
with discrete system,
with length scale between
little mass is actually a,
you get omega square
is equal to 4T
over m sine squared ka over 2.
So if you plot this
omega as a function of k,
you will get the black curve.
What does this
actually tell you?
That is actually telling
you that, if you prepare
a system at a specific normal
mode based on the oscillation
frequency, you can actually
know the internal length
scale of individual
mass, just in case you
didn't notice this
interesting fact.
So thank you very much.
I hope you enjoyed the lecture.
And I will see you
next Thursday--
not here in the Walker room--
Walker Memorial.
So good luck, everybody.
Maybe see some of you in
the office hour tomorrow.